Speaker 1: there is a reason why in this story's
YouTube clip.
I'm using the word accidentally in quotes,
because when it comes to accidentally firing
a gun, we really shouldn't be using the word
accidental.
We should be using the word negligent.
We should be using the word reckless.
The headline, as it's being reported by W.L.
Wex and others, is that a woman had a gun
in her purse during a basketball game.
OK, and she accidentally fired the gun.
I don't think accidentally is really the right
word that we should be using here, but the
story is a woman has been given a $500 bond
after firing a gun at a basketball game in
Madison, Madison, Mississippi, that is according
to police.
The incident happened inside the gym at Rosa
Scott School Monday night during the game.
Khashan Alexis McReynolds reached into her
purse to grab her phone but accidentally fired
her gun.
Nobody was hurt, but the game was suspended
while investigators escorted Mike Runnels
to a secure office inside the school.
McReynolds did have an enhanced concealed
carry permit or permit, some folks like to
say, which allowed her to have the firearm
at the event.
However, she was charged with discharging
a firearm within the city limits of Madison
in violation of the City of Madison ordinance.
Mick Runnels was given a $500 bond and a court
date to appear before Madison Municipal Court.
Accidentally means negligent discharge.
We have to stop normalizing these incidents
by calling them accidents, and that's why
I'm calling this quote accidentally.
It's the wrong word.
It was a negligent discharge that was related
to the reckless handling of a firearm.
Imagine now it didn't happen here, but it
happens all the time.
Imagine ending someone's life with such a
dumb mistake.
It's happened.
We've covered the stories even.
I mean, this is now kind of a whole other
topic in a sense, because some people are
pointing out this was a legal concealed carry
individual license.
Even the classes that are run in many states
are kind of a joke.
As I've said before, I don't talk about whether
I own guns.
So I'm just going to couch this generally.
There are many liberals.
I know that own guns who have said the classes
really can be passed by morons.
And we know that to be true because of the
number of instances where it's not a crime.
Someone who criminally obtained a gun doesn't
have a permit, doesn't have a concealed carry
permit, whatever.
People who are licensed and up to date on
everything that they're supposed to do, who
behave recklessly and negligently with firearms.
And if and until and I'm like a broken record
on this, if an until accidents are actually
treated like the serious negligence that they
are.
I don't think we're going to see anything
change.
The Madison Cawthorn incident is just a perfect
example of this, where Republican Congressman
Madison Cawthorn tried to board a plane from.
I think it was somewhere to Charlotte.
Maybe it was Asheville to Charlotte or something
like that.
And he tried in the sense that he had a firearm
in his carry on.
He tried to board a plane to get through TSA
security with a firearm, and it was shocked
to, oh, it was an accident.
He didn't know the gun was in the bag, as
if that's an excuse.
If you don't know where your firearm is, if
you believe the firearm that you're responsible
for, which is a huge responsibility if you
believe that firearm is in one place and it's
actually in a different place, that's reckless.
That's negligent.
It's not an excuse to say I didn't think it
was in my in my bag.
That's an indication that we should be reviewing
whether you should even be allowed to have
that gun at all.
So we're going to, you know, it's an issue
we're going to continue covering and the extent
to which this is something Democrats should
should be running on.
I've said before, I don't know that it's pragmatically
speaking a good issue to win elections, particularly
in places where it's very purple, purple to
reddish, but it's an issue that's not going
away anytime soon.